in 18c Stadium two days before the draft
and the Rich Eisen show Hari again I'm
kind of excited to be here in person
it's when I first Rich Eisen show in
personal appearance is that right I
always see it on Twitter you know it's
you and it's the celebrity seated to
your right and then now it's me now it's
you to my left your left now - yeah
we're painting the word picture and
we're in a smaller radio booth as
opposed to the 18 t studios in Los
Angeles you are you are eight you're the
NFL Network has set you up in a suite is
that where you're gonna be how about the
entire week doing your hundreds that's
where I'm gonna be during the days okay
nights yes or in the actual broadcast I
will be I believe to your right kind of
off the stage okay in a elevated
elevated position with Roger Goodell
over my left shoulder okay so the
Commissioner will be staring you down is
that what you're you're saying if he
looks to the left okay well very good so
what do you make of the rumor du jour of
Baker Mayfield being the number one
overall selection in this year's draft
yeah I mean I imagine they considered
him that's the past tense right there I
think they I think at this point they
probably know who they're who they're
taking I think he's you know a
possibility definitely one of the top
quarterbacks I would be at this point
surprised if that happened but I've been
surprised before you know and I think
the Browns have done a really good job
of intentionally or not intentionally
making sure that we think at various
points that they will take each of the
top process what does that mean what
does that matter do they want to trade
out of that top spot is that what it is
no I don't think they want to and I
think they will make the pick but you
never quite know what offers are gonna
come your way until not saying this is a
strategic leak at all cuz I guess
theoretically it is possible they take
Baker Mayfield it one would be a
surprise but it is theoretically
possible but maybe what it does is kind
of draw out people who would be willing
to trade or it's just fun and I think
John Dorsey really is enjoying his his
time with all eyes on him I think he is
having a lot of fun well III think he
might be but I don't know if this was
directed by the Browns let's put it out
I think this is somebody who thinks that
they know what John Dorsey is thinking
and threw it out there that Baker
Mayfield is gonna be the number one
overall pick in this draft because they
believe that that is actually happening
for Cleveland and that would surprise me
that would genuinely surprised me
because we haven't been talking about
Mayfield like that at all whatsoever
do you hear of any other Scouts that
would would agree with that assessment
of Baker Mayfield it all I have not I
have not heard from the evaluators who
believe he is the number one overall
player or any honestly now he could has
a very good chance to go three to the
Jets so if he's good enough to go three
then you figure he's good enough to go
one right I mean that that would make
some sense I just look they had Johnny
Manziel I am not at all saying Baker
Mayfield is Johnny Manziel he is
absolutely not
however there are some similarities
there and they would get that question a
lot it's not something that John Dorsey
couldn't handle it's not something Jimmy
Haslam a Hugh Jackson couldn't handle
but it will be a question now I think
one thing that's come out and I've
talked to a lot of gyms about this is
they've all interviewed Baker Mayfield's
teammates a lot of them and he probably
gets more over-the-top praise and
adulation from teammates than probably
any prospect guys are over the moon in
love with Baker guys who play with him
he is a legit leader and if you watch
the way he practices that could be
infectious at the Senior Bowl he was
fantastic so if it happened I don't
think it would be bad at all I think
there's a probably a good chance he
would be successful yes I would still be
surprised
Ian Rapoport of the NFL Network NFL
Media Group our coverage is starting
from this building today and building up
all the way through to pick number one
all the way through to pick number 256
right here on the Rich Eisen show so you
say that the Browns would know right now
that's it they know right now that's
gonna be on the card you do believe that
yeah III think they have a sense now I
mean let me say it differently John
Dorsey knows John Dorsey I read that
yesterday that John Dorsey is not gonna
tell
you Jackson until tomorrow night Joe
banner came out and retweeted that and I
know that obviously there some people
think he has an axe and it's grinding
every now and then when he's when he
ever he tweets about Twitter Leland
Brown really about anything okay
although I love Jonah but but Joe
basically retweeted that saying that if
this is the case then why you even have
the coach around this is a vote of
complete no confidence is that true that
he's not telling you Jackson who he's
thinking yeah I mean well I would say
this I don't think he's telling anyone
there are definitely people in the
organization right now that he's closer
to then then he is to Hugh Jackson and I
don't think those people know either now
I think they have a sense and I'm sure
Hugh has a sense but no one has been
told yes we are picking this guy you
know Dorsey gets it I mean I think he
likes the drama I think he wants all
eyes on the podium and the reality is in
our world and I'm me and my competitors
do a very good job of making sure that
there are very few secrets this so when
he tells someone it's probably gonna get
out I mean if you look back to just
think about recent history he was with
the Chiefs here the number one overall
pick it was Eric Fisher we found out
about 5:00 p.m. with the draft around
7:00 p.m. so he kept it a secret even in
like a tackle draft it wasn't nearly as
much right well there was also not as
much interest like which which tackle
you're gonna take Eric Fisher or Luke
jokl right has nothing on what we're
about to see may be on Thursday night
which is a total surprise potentially
when Roger Goodell comes to the podium
for his first announcement Farmers
Insurance brings this poll question to
you today's poll question is brought to
you by our friends that knows that the
road ahead is bound to take some
unexpected turns farmers insurance can
help you understand your coverage
options with our practical knowledge
gained from more than 90 years of
experience we know a thing or two
because we've seen a thing or two find
an agent at farmers calm ask the poll
question Chris yeah guys who should the
Browns take first overall who should
they take Josh Allen Sam darn old Baker
Mayfield Josh Rose and Bradley Chubb Ian
what about sake one Barclay you didn't
put that in he's on there it's on there
or you just forgot I forgot to put him
on this don't care about right no he's
just know he's a rosin
not taking they're not taking rosin your
rosin honk I am to just do what we
discussed beforehand well IRA
quarterbacks take one I just forgot
leach is amazing how many people will
believe all the quarterback the
evaluation has been all cost of I'll
answer the question a second it is
amazing how many people think that Josh
Rosen is the best film hands down no
question just as a quarterback they
think he is the best for me I would say
they don't have to play him this year
talent wise is not a question I think
Josh Allen would make a lot of sense the
people who know and have worked with
Dorsey think that's the guy that he
likes the big arm is unquestioned to me
you can let him learn for a year or two
I would go with that one okay and then
there's some serious dominoes that would
tumble the minute there we get one name
from the podium and I want to ask you
about that when we come back a 60-second
break what are the Giants gonna do they
hold all the cards in this draft as far
as I'm concerned that they could do
anything I mean there are truly five
options for them to do five of them and
they're all viable and they all make
sense and I'm wondering what the hell
they're thinking and is there any there
there Ian Rapoport don't answer notes
all the t's oh okay
is there any there there to Julio Jones
cleansing having having a social media
cleanse of the Atlanta Falcons
that's next with the Ian Rapoport live
from AT&T Stadium in the Metroplex it's
draft week people back at 60 seconds on
the Richardson show all right we're back
in 18 t stadium Ian Rapoport is here we
who you texting greet typing tell me
what's that oh what is that all about
well is that is that is that a story is
that a breaking story not breaking but
some draft insight draft there's a lot
of insight there's a lot of so what are
you really hearing on this because every
you know
oh one great thing about how it works
walk people through how the information
business works here two days before
draft well what are you getting right
there what I'm getting now is it's all
the the GM's and coaches that don't
always want to talk on the phone all
want to talk
so now because they want to know what
you're here and what other people are
doing who you know what's the buzz about
where this team could go because
everyone wants to be prepared for all
scenarios and so it's a lot of kind of
gossip and then so you're being used
essentially as an information font font
of information but I'm use I'm saying is
that the your your now sources that
you're constantly mining for information
that don't really want to coffin up
throughout a football season seriously
are now turning the tables in a way yeah
with you
yeah and now and that's something you
put in the bank for later on this fall
now that you've got a relationship going
or you already have had it for years
right I mean that's the trading of
information yeah that's sort of what it
is going on and guys will rarely say
like hey you know we're doing this or
they might say hey everyone expects us
to trade up we're not trading up to sort
of set the expectations that happened
some too but yeah it's a lot of like hey
what are you hearing and then like hey
you know we can't give you much about us
but we'll tell you what we hear about
others I'll say a school that's a trade
off phone okay you know then sometimes
they they will help you out with a
little information sometimes I I just
it's a lot of fun like I love this
process so I would do this anyway you
just kind of like given the minds of
some of these guys and and hearing you
know sometimes you can tell about what
questions they ask and you get some hey
do you think this guy is really gonna be
here at you know this pick and you'll
say hmm why did you ask me that
something that now at what point what
percentage of battery space left is you
begin to get nervous that you need a
charge to make sure that your father's
not like what I would say when it goes
from green to red
now I had a difficult experience last
night my phone the one of the plugs
didn't work on my hotels what an Allen D
charge get out of here now no that's a
major occupational hazards happening now
is as I'm holding this phone no case you
notice right the case is now being
separately charged so when I get back my
case will be are you are you team
low-power mode
no come on saves battery life Ian come
on you want to charge well while we're
discussing while we're talking would you
be would you feel better if I charged
you up right now during this
conversation okay and also one last
thing so without the case all right yeah
baby charge it up this side right now
today that's a reaction so right now
just one last thing here without the
case you're going commando right yeah
yeah yeah I mean it's dangerous no
there's no net Wow be careful be careful
have your head on a swivel
nobody needs to bump into you because
then all of a sudden you have your head
on a swivel if you've ever seen a grown
man cry if my phone broke
[Laughter]
I was really fantastic Ian Rapoport here
on the rich has a show what are the
Giants thinking right now best you can
tell best I can tell yes take one
Barkley first of all I agree with you I
think they hold all the cards because
let's say they take let's say it goes al
and Arnold back-to-back mm-hmm
then why I would say you then you might
have a trade up for an odd quarterback
you know you could have a trade up for
shake one Barkley for instance with the
Jets hold on a minute let's start here
again so the the Browns choose a
quarterback
yes Giants are on the clock choose a
quarterback I think they choose a
quarterback I think they take mark they
take Barkley yeah what's the name of the
quarterback that would be remaining on
the draft board that would make them
think twice about taking Barkley the one
thing I don't know is and maybe I will
never know is let's say Alan goes one to
the Browns and Donald is there for the
Giants is that the guy that they say
Willa Barkley but we can't pass that's
what I'm that's so that's the one guy
that would make them get a hitch in
there Barkley giddyup yeah and like you
know now I mean I think they like some
of the other guys but at - you know I
they want a Hall of Famer and I think
for most teams I would say that say Kwan
is the number one player on the board
some teams have Nelson a lot of teams
have say Kwan
Dave gentlemen is very strict as far as
taking best player available so I think
it's gonna be sake one but it's easy for
me to say now if they're on the clock of
Donald's there
I don't know what they're gonna do
welcome me to me
the Giants should because I - if they
have five options they take a
quarterback they take Berkeley they take
Chubb they trade out or they take
Quentin Nelson which would be totally
nuts
but they need him so what I'm saying is
the best move for sure would be trading
out and by that I mean this what's more
likely the bills come all the way up and
make a big trade a big splash with the
Giants or even the Jets even the Jets
should call to make sure that they cuz
the Jets wallets on the clock don't know
who's calling Dave gentlemen if I'm the
Jets I'm doing what the Bears did last
year to move up one spot whatever it
costs if Donald is sitting there at two
that way the Giants pocket something
extra and then sit there at three and
see who wants ya and take away that take
Berkeley where they gonna take anyway
that makes no sense from the stay put it
to ya at all cuz I feel the kettlemans
phones are gonna be ringing from the
Jets from the bills or another team
wouldn't you agree with that yeah I mean
the I would say that trade you described
is probably more likely to me than the
Giants going from 2 to 12 okay I don't
think they want to go all the way back
to 12 now maybe they could trade up like
the Titans did a couple years two years
back whenever that was but there's no
guarantee so like you know and if if
you're the Jets if people made fun of
the Bears last year I did not like if
you think you have a franchise
quarterback and if you believe true
bisque is it you pay whatever you have
to give up a third-round or like who
cares
third rounders are flip a coin right so
if you're the Jets and you say I want to
guarantee we get Sam Donald it does it
merit or Mayfield or whoever the guys I
don't care who it is you want to
guarantee who who it is right and you
have to give up a fourth round or like
you will survive all right be fine Ian
Rapoport here on the Rich Eisen show a
few quick hitters as well Dez Bryant
latest what can you tell me of what's
going on with him I don't get the sense
anything is imminent
I think that the Ravens were definitely
interested I think if Dez wanted to be
with the Ravens that deal probably would
have happened instead of where does he
want it what's he holding out hope for
an NFC East team yeah I think he's still
hoping for the Giants I don't get the
sense that's gonna happen at this point
I think it might take a while okay so
that's a post draft situation possibly
what happened with Julio Jones and his
social media accounts that I have yet to
know he did want to cleanse apparently a
fresh start on social media there are
things that happen for players that do
not necessarily involve football I have
not yet linked this to a football reason
I will say that so I don't think for
what other reason I've heard like other
what what business deals or something
like that that he needs to because what
business deal does he have that wouldn't
want to trade off on the fact that he's
one of the most famous and football
players wearing an Atlanta Falcon
uniform that makes no sense
sounds like question I read that too I
read that day well he's got a business
deal and that's what so what business
deal would want him hey here's what we
want we want you to go private on
Twitter so nobody could see anything and
we want you to remove any aspect of your
Atlanta Falcon miss from may be you're
gonna have to grab hey to hear Julio
Jones on Twitter now is he good on to it
I'll actually follow half a million
followers so are the are the Falcons
freaked up to our famine followers are
the Falcons damn straight you look at
you talking smack your brothers are very
joe ingles on and on russell westbrook
moment right there i'm paul george type
moment right there you're the joe ingles
of social media but so other falcons
freakin ten sound like okay doesn't
sound like it and are and the giants lot
finally somebody from the giants today
came out and said Odell's not going
anywhere they just flat-out said it yet
remember flat-out final we said which is
nice i mean probably could have said it
a couple weeks ago reality is yes to
trade a awesome player it rarely it
almost never happens and it was not
gonna happen in this case okay name of a
player who's dropping that you're
hearing right now
uh I would say Darius Geiss is probably
having gonna have a difficult week I
thought he was gonna be a first round
why I don't think so now I didn't sound
like his meetings went great it's not
because he said what somebody asked him
if he if you like man is it camp is that
real can't be that if if they found out
if they found out he lied it would not
be good okay and they have not yet found
out that he's told the truth okay so
that is still ongoing but it has not
been corroborated yet okay and that's
not great
and somebody you shooting up the draft
boards that you're hearing uh shooting
up the draft boards I would say
McGlinchey the tackle probably goes
higher than we think
sorry Patriots aren't getting there that
would be one I think great
I think Edmunds Nina is a sure is a
Sherlock doctor pick a linebacker
tremendous who everybody loves I mean I
literally haven't had anyone say a bad
word about him I think he definitely
goes in the top ten that's another one
and I think Denzel Ward will go higher
than people think okay thanks for coming
on in we'll look forward to working with
you all week you have to give your what
do you what do you out right now what do
you I'm at 30 a game thirteen I was like
a really I gained ten percent when I
Mike it's Mike tell to foes famous a
fast charger he's so proud of his fast
charger seriously guess he had children
he wouldn't be as proud of his children
as the use of his fast charge hey listen
asked me back for your charger anytime
okay and be careful Lorin Parker of of
our show we'll make sure that nobody
comes within any five-foot radius of you
without protection for yourself I
appreciate okay so Lauren but Lauren
Parker be your figurative protective
case so she makes her way make your way
back to the NFL Network position that's
Ian Rapoport everybody the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience